[Music]
vcm is a movie that takes place in the
in the future and it takes place in a
futuristic Los Angeles and in this
future Los Angeles is all
spanish-speaking yeah it's it's
basically everyone trying to get a
ticket to Elysium so we shot in weird
places I I had to wait for Matt Damon to
wanna go and see the dumps of my city to
actually see the dumps of my city and
it's that's kind of strange that you get
cash this movie and that's okay I told
everyone I'll come to Mexico you're
gonna have a great experience I'll take
you everywhere around and then we drive
to the dumps and I'm like [ __ ] what is
this
yeah and then I go into the trailer and
when I come out this is the Mexican
coming out with a big mask the glasses
like if I was in the moon you know
everyone looking at me like thank you
he's scared of you Early's I'm sure they
didn't say that he said something much
more appropriate for television yeah
you're fine writing Spanish you could
say in Spanish yeah can I say but in
Spanish and
OOP yeah I think you're he's allowed to
swear in Spanish right am I go to town
what do you mean no no I not
well what do you hear the Jewish
producer from New York is like Amy swear
in Spanish do you speak Spanish yeah you
don't know what he said oh I don't want
to know where he's what's he's doing
okay that's okay so this is in the
future they're prophesizing in this
movie that everybody speaks Spanish well
yeah cuz that's sort of the way it's
going yeah and it's not gonna take so
long so do you speak Spanish
that's why I asked your producer yes I'm
poquito yo Boris paniolo okay but anyway
I could go on and on but I don't
now if you if you want to keep your job
in this network you're gonna have to
learn Spanish you know there's like yes
because the country it's all changing
over ya seven million people speak
Spanish today and we like having sex so
multiply that four eight ten years
another eighth in another ten years
see you won't be done it's better that
it's verdad um only the rest of us like
having sex it's just so much work thanks
to much yeah you much work it's her
trade gets too high okay so I'm curious
Diego what is it what's a phrase you I
should learn if I'm gonna exist what's
not you want to survive in the future in
this country you have to know numb which
is an expression look no come what does
that mean I mean literally means do not
suck or don't suck it don't suck it like
the lollipop obviously don't suck the
lollipop
no no no don't suck that lollipop
not a few kid look but no I mean be
careful never with kids never kids no no
no I just said what did you do
when you done to me you loved your dog I
just lost my job
yeah but no could be used in many ways
it could be like no like no way no
really but it could be also not I mean
don't know don't mess around don't f
with me
aha exactly don't have my lollipop
the other one is capital k pedo is very
good what's that one pedo means fart so
when you say hey pedo it's like hey
what's up no k pedo
what's your fart how does the fart smell
today does it work at all those it
doesn't work at all hey how's it going
what's the for today it does